kovat 19 is a disease caused by a new
corona virus that was identified in
China it is thought to spread from
person to person when people are close
together and through droplets produced
when a sick person coughs or sneezes
currently there is no treatment for
kovat 19 the best way to keep yourself
from getting sick is to avoid being
exposed to the virus one way to protect
yourself is to clean your hands often
wash your hands often with soap and
water for at least 20 seconds if soap
and water aren't available use a hand
sanitizer it should contain at least 60%
alcohol avoid touching your face with
unwashed hands another way to protect
yourself is to avoid close contact with
other people this includes avoiding
contact with sick people and put a
distance between yourself and others by
staying home as much as possible if you
have to go out aim to keep a minimum of
6 feet between yourself and others when
possible for more information visit the
website for the Centers for Disease
Control